breaking news for this morning we're  just hearing the research is underway  from three year old British girl who's  gone missing in the Algarve area of  Portugal and she went missing last night  [Music]  you  [Music]  the latest development appears to be a  focus on three main suspects two men and  a woman who were seen with a girl  resembling Madeline  [Music]  [Music]  Oh Kate in Gerry McCann have both been  today declared and we think the  inference was was the term the Scotland  Yard investigation was going to be very  narrowly focused and that focus would be  away from any suspicion of wrongdoing on  the part of the reckons or the Pappas  friends  [Music]